i can't tell are the players
chit-chatting is that what's going on
the game is starting no one get no one
told me except you michelle thank you
oh damn you and you're sicilian i hate
the sicilian oh my god he knows the names
yeah are more than i do wait they're they're
just trying to talk about what to do here
this is bad because he's going to push
it again and then reopen that diagonal
yeah we may have a we may have a new favorite
this is a pretty harsh harsh opening but man
this is a brutal start oh my gosh this
is really rough oh no oh no oh no oh no
it's everything that we
thought was going to happen yes
the bishop opens up again he just gets the bishop
out and i don't even know what i'm playing anymore
this is so strange that is unfortunately how it
works sometimes it's how i feel when i play hikaru
the only public game on this profile that
he has is against magnus carlsen that's it
like clearly he plays somewhere else on something
else he's gotten coaching he obviously works with
uh you know danny talked yesterday about how he's
had a long relationship with chess and chess.com
we know nothing about the guy it's like in a
video game hikaru where you know nothing about
a boss and the recent you know article
on the website or newspaper the the mo
like the book hasn't been published how to beat
that boss so you just keep trying i feel like
i lose no matter what i do here i don't even
if i go here he goes here and this is such a
difficult scenario i feel like i just have to go
here now there's literally nowhere for me to go
i have no idea what else i'm supposed to do
no idea it made the game go longer so we'll
see what happens oh no and now he's going
to go work do you want to queen the egg
is he actually going to do that or
is he going to take on a phase stop
okay if he plays rook d1 okay he just
takes the bishop good okay good at
least at least he didn't play rook do
you want to queen the eight made okay
he literally would have had i mean that would
have been the problem would have been like a 99
cap score for accuracy i think yes very close
to it yes rookie one was mate in two it is still
it is still game over rook d1 is probably
still the professional move here i mean and
unbelievable not even knight e5 not even 95 which
a lot of people would play just chasing the king
crazy pretty harsh pretty pretty harsh is he going
to play queen e8 preventing the escape to beef oh
my god he prevents the king from escaping he
doesn't even give a check wow so who's going
to call danny and tell him that he might have
messed up with this invitation oh no and queenie
seven and rook d8 oh yeah yeah this is i hope
he hasn't pre-moved it that would be even worse
yeah queen d8 and as well as queen
v6 with some mates but he just
goodness me geez brutal first game oh
my gosh harsh wow how was your day going
my day's good yeah i i i exercised
today michelle there you go
yeah yeah i ran around and lifted some
weights i took a shower you look great
i'm well groomed well i'm not very well groomed
my hair how about you what have i been up to um
i was what i was playing chess before this um oh
yeah i took a lesson with my chess master coach
with danny he's the worst he's a double agent he
gave me a like i kick his ass every time he can't
even beat me i'm like oh you're going to lecture
me oh wow i'm just kidding i would believe that
he's way better she's been looking
at london queen's gambit systems uh
throughout uh she has a kind of a a little group
chat uh with with myself with anna with the other
anna anna kremling but she's done lessons with
everybody because ultimately she is filming
her show and i think she made a
big effort to kind of reach out
uh to the community probably after this one uh
maybe you'll have to give oh this is actually
she's getting her old opening played against
her so rayne wilson is a king's indian guy
interesting she used to play this she started out
with the setup so all right let's see what happens
wait sorry oh my god i cannot believe he just
did that i cannot believe he just did that oh no
no oh danny's getting an angry message he's
not getting one now i'm gonna have to think
how to write it but this is not this will
not be a polite hr email the whole team's
gonna have to get involved already ah not
even a moment not even a moment to breathe
yeah this is uh this is unfortunately
one of those things i'm gonna go
uh knight d2 good good open up my queen
yes this is one of those things in london
hikar you get hit with it once you never
get hit with it again this early queen
ah she might defend her bishop with
the queen and hang the rook that's the
problem this is unprotected okay so i need to move
this you're in check i i will say i really do like
the way i do like the move she's finding like this
is really really rough um for her but she's still
like the she makes these blunders but she's still
finding a way to find good moves even after the
blunders i think that's really really important
to note um yes yes like bishop b5 is a very very
good move yes yes this is exciting for me okay
if she plays knight takes pawn f3 to win okay i
think i'm gonna take with the knight because it's
protected by the pawn come on just do it go for it
i wish there was a way i could take an attack i
know we're listening into her i will just say uh
as someone who has worked with her even the first
chess lesson protect my work which is nice okay
the first lesson that she ever took uh
and ever since then i've kind of like
i don't think we're gonna get queen f3 though he
car i'm not gonna lie i think she's gonna take
back right but i mean rain is just destroying
everything here like he doesn't he's getting
rid of the great bishop on that on the dark
squares so there's a lot of danger here for black
queen enough three come on one two good he's
too good three come on i need to get my rook
she was caught off guard by queen d4 but she saw
it that's the thing like she has to trust herself
she saw it she saw take stakes she didn't need
to say damn it like that was gonna happen and
now she's winning but she's in the wrong mindset
she's not thinking i'm gonna beat this guy she's
thinking i gotta survive i gotta queen f3
aggressive and you win the rook yeah yeah
okay not the best move but i mean again
oh queen takes what queen takes queen
what
she doesn't even see it she's only
looking at her rook under attack
oh oh she's i think she spotted it
she took she took its game on oh
what happened see i told you michelle
oh oh no wow you got me good are you serious
yeah i just totally blundered i just didn't even
i was just like oh i'll go over there it happens
oh my god okay guys it's game time but
now you have six minutes to meet me
okay i'm just gonna i gotta
get my rook out of the way
and to protection i think i'm gonna go here puts
in check he can't castle the only defense is
okay there are two there's that knight oh
my god i need to think michelle just move
you don't you don't need to think six
moves ahead just go you're up a queen
european
okay okay i can't go here i can't i can't i
can't go there can't go there can't go there
i can go here oh my gosh she
can make any one of those moves
and it's all those moves are checked
so do i want to go here or here
okay i'm gonna go
b2 i'm thinking b2 because then it protects
this pawn yes it's also check all right all
right all right all right all right all
right all right all right i mean sometimes
when you get a gift like that it's hard to react
right because you're winning and you're like
hold up yeah very very true if
she wins then she gets to play
in our first tie break which we thought we
would have today actually multiple times
if you go here i go here
oh my god okay i need to calm down is the
living example of all of our emotions when
we play chess okay maybe not you hikaru but
this is i think as much as we try to contain it
you know what okay uh i i literally have no
idea what else to do so i'm just gonna take
pawns i know that's not the best strategy but
um here we are actually no okay that made sense
i don't know i've done the puzzles guys i've
done the puzzles okay you know if anything
this is a testament to how hard what is that
chess okay here here to threaten the bishop no
okay i gotta move faster oh she's got two two
minutes oh wait oh wait here and check you're in
check e5 i all i need all i know how to do is just
put things in check that's all i know how to do
for now it's fun oh my god jesus christ the
rook is hanging a7 is not good just because
you lose the pawn not because you lose the
rook right exactly yeah that's oh good move
sharp play from her she's also evolving
throughout this game it feels like
that's it get it out push the pawn
it's over i mean it's the next wave
i know she sees it yeah
good move
king h4 okay g3 you know what the crazy
she she might put her king in the corner
and get okay no but she has to check the king
here okay oh this is so close and now he's
gonna try to smother and checkmate oh that's a
great move there you go that's it just take it
and now it's impossible
now it's impossible but she
has to win no stalemates
and she's definitely done she's definitely done
ladder mates she's definitely well done michelle
it's not it's not over yet
it's not over it's so good
i'm shaking
great i couldn't i thought i had you
there i did kind of have you but i
flew it again i really blew this game well done
really good oh thank you this almost
feels like borgov harmon you know
the final scene where he he but okay please
don't bring your clock perfectly i kicked my
ass i don't want a tubbo situation hikaru
oh i hope something against logic yeah
that's it yeah congratulations oh my god
that was insane i have no feeling in my hands
oh my gosh michelle obama michelle come youtube
come back for white four minutes for black but
if the game ends in a draw black is the winner
correct likelihood that happens to win the game oh
yeah this game has gotten oh oh oh no it's mate if
it well takes and you can't take back yeah no oh
what a butthole wow it's so fast
okay 155 the clock is ticking
oh she blundered it back but she gets
a rook but she did blunder it back
right that's true yeah that's true she michael
rook 8 she played so nervous and now he can take
the knight he does see it rookie six fork and then
knight e7 check probably a good move by michelle
very very very good move i like the way that she's
playing throughout this match um even though she
is over match she has found a lot of good moves
they're just c6 yes and and seven and bishop and
queen just queen and mate queen and mate it looks
like rain wilson's gonna pull it out correct yes
all right take the rook and uh
oh what did i do
i'm sorry okay uh where were we left
well looks like he's gonna he looks
like he's gonna finish the game
and well now literally any move and uh yeah and
reigns wow that was really pathetic oh my god
oh my god nine seconds left
i can't feel my hands oh no that was
uh that was very very much that was
wow you played so great you really played
way better than me honestly really did you
had a minute left you had a minute less than
me i forgot that oh my god it's gone less than
me she played great by the way that's all i
want to say michelle played amazing she like
learned like a month ago or something like that
she watched like queen's gambit and said i'm
going to be bethlehem and then she took me to
the mat and played just fantastic especially
with her clock um that's what she said this
is probably the first big mental challenge
i've had to take on and let me tell you it's
equally as stressful it is equally as stressful
as you know rappelling down a tower with the
us marine corps or doing being in a burning
building i can't feel my hands right now this was
so stressful and with the audience oh my gosh like
especially in the first game um i i clearly made a
lot of blunders and had a big learning opportunity
there but the chess community is incredible
i have loved um getting to stream chess and
learn from you levy and anna kramling and anna
rudolph and so many other wonderful people and
i just love how welcoming you guys are and
uh i i'm going to hydrate a lot after this
you